[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América
Rosa Pérez mateu en el estudio Rosa
bienvenida buena mañana de miércoles ya
estamos a mitad de semana y vamos a
hablar de que hoy también se cumplen los
40 días desde que murió la joven iraní
maxsa mini tras ser detenida por la
policía de la moral recordemos en
Teherán por presuntamente llevar mal
puesto el velo islámico el jillab rosa
que hay sobre esto bien Raúl pues
encontramos que a primera hora de la
mañana había pocos medios
internacionales que hicieran referencia
precisamente a esta fecha como bien lo
comentabas a estos 40 días que han
pasado desde el 16 de septiembre cuando
maxa mini recordemos una joven kurdo
iraní Murió como bien decías bajo
custodia de la policía de la moral del
país sin embargo esta fecha estos 40
días tienen una especial importancia
porque en Irán se conmemora
Especialmente cuando han pasado estos 40
días que se hace con el día 3 y el día 7
después de la muerte y bien de Guardian
lo que hace es una breve repaso a través
de un vídeo que a continuación vamos a
ver en nuestras pantallas en los que
muestran un poco el movimiento masivo
que se desató a raíz de la muerte de
máxima mini sobre todo este movimiento
estas manifestaciones empezaron el 17 no
el día de su funeral Y a partir de ese
momento vimos muchas mujeres que
empezaron liderando estas protestas
quitándose el velo quemándolo luego vino
lo de cortarse el pelo no unas protestas
que sobre todo han estado protagonizadas
como decíamos por mujeres por jóvenes y
por la diáspora iraní fuera del país
protestas que continúan el día de hoy
Rossi que también ongs ya denuncian que
las fuerzas de seguridad pues dispararon
munición Real contra algunos
manifestantes pero vamos ahora a Londres
ahí está el medio iraní Avenue
exactamente y aquí ya nos centramos como
bien comentabas en lo que está pasando a
día de hoy no y es que Precisamente en
el cementerio de donde está la tumba de
macza Minnie en la ciudad curda de
saques sean congregado una multitud de
personas a pesar de que la fuerza
pública había bloqueado los principales
accesos a esta ciudad pero como nos
comentaba Catalina desde Irán no muchas
personas acudieron a la pueblo natal de
maxada Mini andando saltándose estos
bloqueos y precisamente no Irán
internacional recoge vídeos que han sido
publicados en las redes sociales desde
primera hora de esta mañana hora de Irán
en las que vemos a una multitud como
decíamos en el cementerio gritando
jamenes edad derrocado este año o en la
típico eslogan no que se ha coreado en
estos 40 días de protestas al grito de
mujer vida y Libertad muerte al dictador
o el kurdistán será la tumba de los
fascistas veamos Este vídeo en que se
escucha de forma muy clara la la palabra
allá di que es libertad en persa
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Exacto Esto fue esta mañana Raúl hace
hace unas horas y en otras noticias no
irá en International por ejemplo
menciona y llama a maxa un icono de Irán
No ya un icono de estas protestas que
como decíamos empezaron por la cuestión
de una protesta contra este estricto
código de vestimenta de las mujeres pero
que ella es una movimiento contra el
régimen de la República islámica y en
otras noticias vemos en ir a la
International que continúan bloqueados
muchos canales de mensajería y de redes
sociales a pesar que los analistas Pues
citados en esto En este medio en este
artículo consideran y explican que las
autoridades se iranís tienen varios
varias cuentas en distintas redes
sociales y que en realidad muchas
personas en Irán utilizan VPN para
utilizar para tener acceso a estas redes
sociales sobre todo a WhatsApp Instagram
Telegram que se considera que un 75% de
los iraníes de más de 18 años usa estos
medios de comunicación y también
hablando de comunicación la ong
human right se dice que ya son más de
100 los muertos 108 si no me equivoco
los muertos tras esta represión vamos
con ironwire Exacto que por ejemplo
estima citando otras ongs que serían más
de 200 las personas ha fallecidas por la
represión de la fuerza pública en las
protestas y Iron water lo que destaca es
lo que comentábamos no que estas
protestas se centraron primero en el
estricto código de vestimenta de las
mujeres pero que pronto se convirtió en
uno de los principales desafíos en los
últimos años contra el régimen de Irán y
rápidamente Comenta que la televisión
iraní Estatal iraní Pues que sufre una
traviesa una Pérdida total de
legitimidad precisamente por parte de la
población iraní que sea acentuado a raíz
de su cobertura de estas protestas que
ha sido considerada Pues de una falta de
objetividad total y de estar pues
alineada totalmente con las autoridades
y es que sin ir más lejos el director de
la televisión pública iraní está elegido
nombrado directamente por el líder
supremo entonces pues se entiende
digamos esta falta de objetividad si se
puede llevar así en todo caso Raúl
estaremos muy pendientes siguiendo muy
de cerca lo que continua pasando en Irán
Así es rosa porque no queremos pues
dejarlo a un lado esta grabación que
ocurre en Irán como siempre Gracias por
información mañana con más revista de
prensa